Today, we are going to continue
thinking about reactions.
Just to remind you, what
did we do on Friday?
So we introduced-- here's
what we did last time.
We talked about constant--
we talked about reactions.
And there, on Friday, we were
really interested in rates--
how fast is it happening.
So we talked about things that
affect the reaction rate--
concentration.
Concentration versus time,
and how you can measure that.
And you can have rate loss based
on experimental measurements.
And that can tell you
the reaction order.
We talked about zero, first,
second-order reactions,
the rate constant,
and then we also
talked about the
temperature dependence.
And at the very end, the role
of a catalyst in lowering
that activation barrier.
Today, we're going to talk
about how things dissolve.
So we're going to
talk about solubility,
and this has to do with
reactions because something
dissolving is a reaction.
But what's going
to happen is we're
going to talk about how that
reaction finds its happy place.
And we know a happy
place is a good thing,
and it's called equilibrium.
And so that's going to
involve talking about things
like equilibrium
constants, dissolution,
we're going to look
at some examples
with ionic compounds-- so salts.
We're going to be
dissolving salts in water
and looking at how to think
about how much of that
dissolves in terms
of the equilibrium
constant for the reaction.
So that's the goal today.
I want to start, though, by
talking about why this matters,
and that's directly
related to your goodie bag.
So this is something some
of you may have seen.
The data here in
from the '50s is
from the Mauna Loa measurements,
the top of a volcano.
And this is CO2 concentration,
parts per million
in the atmosphere.
But if you dig into the ice--
we're going to be
doing a lot of that
here in Boston over
the next three months.
But if you dig deeper into
the ice, in the cores,
you go back in time, and
it's a beautiful thing.
The ice as you go down
is ancient atmosphere.
That's cool-- because
there's little bubbles.
Remember, we talked
about the half life
of carbon-14 that's trapped from
a living thing breathing it in.
Well, you can trap
directly the little bubbles
of atmosphere in the ice,
and that's what happens.
And that's why we know what
CO2 levels-- we're going back
almost a million years here.
It's 800,000 years of data.
And this is a graph that I
think many of you have seen.
It's going up, a lot.
And here it is.
Now, this is just
zooming in on the last 50
or so-- this is just the
data, the Mauna Loa data.
And The reason is
because here we also
have another kind of data.
So there's a lot of
attention paid on CO2,
and there should be.
There is a lot less
attention paid to what
that is doing to our oceans.
And this is a reaction that
we will talk about more when
we talk about acidification.
So when we talk about
acids and bases,
which is coming up later--
later being Wednesday
and next week--
we'll talk more about this.
But I just want to
tell you that when
you have CO2 in the
atmosphere going up,
then you also have CO2
in the ocean going up.
So the CO2 in the ocean--
the CO2 in the atmosphere is
getting absorbed by the ocean.
So what?
No, it's a lot of what,
because what happens
is the CO2 in the ocean--
the more CO2 in the ocean--
is making the ocean more acidic.
So if you just write
this number down--
because it's so astonishing.
Past 200 years, the ocean
has become 30% more acidic.
Now that is the fastest-known
change in the ocean chemistry
in 50 million years.
That's a big and
very sudden change.
So the ocean is absorbing about
22 million tons per day of CO2.
And that number is going up.
Why does that matter?
Maybe it will do
to the oceans what
it's doing to the atmosphere and
making things a little warmer.
No, it's doing more,
because when it acidifies,
then it has a direct
impact on things
like this, which is a pteropod.
You look at the food
chain of the ocean-- there
are three things at the bottom.
That's one of them.
I mean, there's plants.
There's photosynthesis.
And then there's the
bottom of the food chain.
Now you know what's
going to happen
when the bottom of the
food chain disappears.
This is one of the
main kinds of animals
that lives at the
bottom of ocean
because they've got these very
small calcium carbonate shells.
If you make the
ocean just a little
more acidic, like we're doing,
those shells don't survive,
and those animals don't survive.
So that's what
happens to a pteropod.
At the rate we're going--
like decades of time from
now-- that's what happens.
So what you have
in your goodie bag
is a way to see this a
little bit more accelerated.
So here's your goodie bag.
So I wanted you to--
I wanted you to see what's
happening in the ocean,
and you have now the
tools to do that.
So in your goodie bag,
you've got citric powder.
Imagine you take a lot of
limes, and you squeeze them,
and then you dry it all out.
And that's what you got--
citric acid.
Now you're going to mix that
with water to change the ph.
And you're going to
dissolve this powder.
That's the topic of today's
lecture-- dissolution
and equilibrium.
So you're going to
mix that into water,
and you've got a scale
from a previous goodie bag.
So my hope is that you've been
using that on a daily basis.
You take it with you places,
and you can use that again here.
And you'll need that,
because I want you to see
how these shells dissolve.
And if you lower
the acidity more--
we don't want to wait 40--
well, you can wait
45 days, but I
want you to be able to do
these experiments in minutes.
So we're going to go a little
lower in acidity, in ph,
but you're going to
get the same result.
You're going to
dissolve these shells.
Some of you are going
on planes, and there's
white powder and a scale
involved in this goodie bag.
Please don't put that
in your carry-on.
It's just not a good--
it really isn't a good idea.
We have data-- students sending
me pictures with the airport
screening person.
So I love the
excitement of thinking
about this over Thanksgiving,
but put it in your suitcase
if you're going to take it home.
That's my why this matters.
So we're dissolving stuff today.
That's the topic.
How do things dissolve?
There's a citric
powder, that citric acid
that's going to make
water more acidic.
And again, we're going to move
into acids and bases next.
Today we're just talking
about dissolution.
And so here's citric acid.
There it is.
Now over Thanksgiving, I
thought I'd throw this in,
because you might have
sugar at the table.
You know to call it a c12h22o11.
Don't ask for the sugar.
If you want to add some
sugar to something,
ask for it by molecular name.
But the question is
why do these things
dissolve in the first place.
There is acetic acid,
citric acid, there's sugar.
These are molecules
that look like that.
Why do they dissolve
in the first place?
And the answer is
because of the things
that we learned about
bonding and about things
like whether a molecule
is polar or not.
Or in this case, whether
you've got the possibility
to hydrogen bond or not.
And so if you look
at both of these,
you can see that they both
have a whole bunch of oh groups
that look a whole lot
like things we've seen
that like to hydrogen bond.
You see those ohs
on the end there,
both for sugar, around the
outside, and for citric acid.
And so what happens is if I put
a sugar molecule into water,
here's a picture of it.
There's a picture of it.
So there's sugar
molecules there.
Now they start in a
crystal of sugar--
you pour your sugar in,
a teaspoon of sugar.
And it's in a solid,
but then it goes off,
and it breaks away
into the water.
And those little ones
are the water molecules.
Why?
Because the water was
bonding to itself.
The water has dipoles--
dipole-dipole.
Remember that?
The water has hydrogen bonds,
but the sugar does, too.
The sugar does, too.
And so the water sees
this crystal of sugar,
and it says well, hang on.
If you come out, we could bond
together in much the same way
that we're already
bonding with each other.
The water molecules are already
bonding with hydrogen dipole.
The sugar is like, well I've
got hydrogen. I've got dipole.
And so it can break off, and it
doesn't cost that much energy.
In fact, it gains
energy by doing this.
They can gain.
And so this can actually be
a lower energy state overall.
Now that's because of
something that many of you
have probably heard, and now
we can put some bonding to it,
but it's because
like dissolves like.
Oh yeah.
That's technical.
That's technical because
now we know what like means.
Like means a type of body.
like means a type of--
It's like water.
It has hydrogen
bonding potential.
Therefore, it's able to
dissolve in the water.
So water has-- well,
what does water have?
It's got dipoles, so it
can do dipole-dipole stuff.
It's got h-bonds.
Oh, everything has London.
Everything has London.
So if you've got
those ingredients,
if you've got that
ability, if you've got
those likes, then you
might be able to dissolve.
Well, this is called
a polar solvent
because the molecules
that make it up are polar.
They've got dipole.
Actually, and so we're very
interested in understanding
how things mix with
other things and why
they mix with other things.
Let's take a look
at another example.
So here we have ethanol.
I keep on bringing up ethanol.
There might be some served,
and if you're 21 or over,
you can have some.
Otherwise, it's illegal.
Ethanol up there at the top.
Thank goodness, you will say,
at your Thanksgiving table,
it is not methoxymethane.
And because if it were, it would
be the same chemical formula,
but the oh--
the o would be in the
middle of the two cs
with the ch3s on the
end, and you wouldn't
be able to hydrogen bond it.
It would all just be vapor.
It'd be vapor.
No, but it's ethanol because
it has hydrogen bonding
capabilities.
But look at what happens
if it's heptanol.
So all I've done now is I've
taken the same end group,
and I've given it more
of a carbon chain.
How is that going to
affect how it dissolves?
Given what we just
talked about that
like dissolve-- they both
have hydrogen bond potential.
They both have hy-- but
look, more and more of it,
as you go from ethanol to
heptanol, more and more
and more of it is
something else.
It's only London.
So what's going to happen
now if I put this into water?
Well, we can see
this going series.
Here's methanol, ethanol,
propanol, butanol, pentanol,
hexanol.
Heptanol is down at
the bottom, and there's
the water solubility.
We've got to write that down--
solubility.
So solubility is kind
of what it sounds like--
the ability for a solute--
that's the thing
we're dissolving--
to dissolve in a solvent.
That's the thing we're
trying to dissolve it into.
That's the solubility.
And we'll be talking about
the maximum solubility
in just a few minutes,
which is what we usually--
what's the solubility?
We often mean the maximum.
Well, that's what's
listed here--
the maximum.
Methanol, ethanol miscible.
So you can put as much as
you want, and it'll always
keep mixing in with the water.
But now look, once you get to
butanol, pentanol, hexanol,
it starts going down.
You can't mix as
much as you want.
In fact, it's less
and less and less,
and the reason we now know is
because of what I just said.
As you go down, the hydrogen
bond and dipole-dipole
becomes less important
because you've
got more and more of the
molecule that's only London.
And so it's less like the
water environment, the bonding
environment that the
water liked with itself.
And so it has more
trouble dissolving
and being
energetically favorable
isolated by those
water monitors.
By the way, does anybody know
the origin of the word proof,
speaking of ethanol?
If you buy a bottle of
ethanol at the supermarket--
so there's gin or
vodka or whatever,
and it says it's something
percent alcohol--
20% alcohol, 40 proof.
Does anybody know
where that comes from?
It's this.
It's just-- but
what they did, they
didn't know if you were making
good alcohol back in the time.
And they said,
well, I don't have
all these detailed abilities
to measure and quantify it,
so I was going to
light it on fire.
That is exactly what--
is this a good bottle of gin?
I don't know.
Let's light it on fire.
That's what they did.
And it turns out that if ethanol
and water are at 50/50 mixture
or more, it will light on fire.
Don't try that, please.
Don't do these experiments.
But so that meant is this
a good bottle of gin?
Well if it's 50/50, I'm going to
say it's a good bottle of gin.
So let's light it on fire.
Oh, it lit on fire.
That's 100% proof
that it's good.
That is true.
That is the origin
of the word proof.
It is proof that it's mixed
well, and it's good stuff.
Dissolution-- dissolution--
well, what else
can we try to dissolve?
We're dissolving alcohol.
We're going down to heptanol.
We're lucky it's
not methoxymethane.
We talked about sugar.
So we've got to have a
framework, by the way.
Solubility-- the ability
for a solute to dissolve.
And now, there's a
context here, right?
Let's suppose I'm
dissolving sugar.
So sugar-- how are we going
to write this dissolving down?
Well, sugar is c12h22o11, and
if we put it in water, we could
we could formally write
the whole thing out.
We can write it out.
We can say I'm going
to add water to it,
and that's going to go to--
it's going to go to
c12h22o11 plus more water.
But there's something very
important that I'm leaving out,
and when you think
about dissolution,
you've got to keep track.
What was it?
Was it a solid?
Was it a liquid?
Or was it something
dissolved in a liquid?
So this started as a solid,
so we put an s there.
This started as a liquid.
This is the dissolved
thing, so we put an aq.
And the aq means aqueous.
It is in an aqueous solution.
It is a dissolved molecule.
And so here, this is a liquid.
Now the other thing
that happens is-- well,
the h2o is kind of there.
It's all over the place.
It's that solvent,
and so we often
leave it out because it's
everywhere on both sides.
And so often, what
you'll see, and we'll
write more of these coming,
is that you might write
a dissolution of sugar as this.
Solid, and it just goes to
something that is dissolved.
And you know that what
happened there is sometimes
you'll also see it like this.
What did you do on the arrow?
I added water.
That's what the arrow did.
We're just getting comfortable
with writing these dissolution
reactions.
Now what else can I dissolve?
Well here's another
good example--
vitamin A. There's some
vitamins you can have as much
as you want, pretty much.
Why?
Because they're water-soluble.
And other vitamins
are fat-soluble.
That means they
don't like water as
much as they like the
hydrophobic molecules
of fat cells.
And so they go
into fatty tissue,
where they don't come out.
That's why you not have
unlimited amounts of vitamin
A. That's not good for you.
But vitamin C-- no problem.
No problem, because it's
going to dissolve in water.
And so your body can take in
and get rid of as much of it
as you want.
But if it's dissolved
in fat cells,
that's a different thing.
So vitamin A,
vitamin C-- and you
can see it right there
from the chemistry.
This is it.
Look at all those oh
groups in vitamin c.
Look at that.
Oh, that's going to
love hydrogen bonding,
and on vitamin A, you've just
got the one all the way down
there at the bottom.
It's hydrophobic.
By the way, in this
class, we do not
say the words
hydrophobic interaction
because that doesn't make sense.
There is no such thing as
a hydrophobic interaction.
No, hydrophobic
interaction is misused.
What it really means is that
something that's hydrophobic
likes itself more--
being together with
itself-- more than it
likes being in the water,
or something hydrophilic.
That's what is meant, but
there's no actual interaction
there.
Hydrophobic, hydrophilic.
Well, those are other things
you can think about dissolving.
You can also dissolve
salt, and this is what
we're going to use as examples.
And this is a picture
of a salt crystal.
So we show the sugar,
and here's salt. Now,
so the thing about salt--
where's my sugar?
There's the sugar, and let's
put salt underneath it.
The thing about
salt, which is really
just a general term for when
you have an ionic solid that
can be made from a mixture of
acids and bases and dissolves
oftentimes a little
bit, at least in water.
So a salt or an ionic solid--
let's say for now--
this gives something different,
because this breaks apart
into positive and negative
ions that they contain.
So in the case of sodium and
chlorine-- sodium chloride--
well, that's going
to dissociate.
If you pour salt in water, then
here's the reaction for that.
You've got sodium
chloride solid.
We put it in water.
That's going to go into ions.
So I put that in water, and
it's different in the sense
that it doesn't break down
into the molecules that
made up the sugar.
It has a particle
of sugar that's
got millions and millions
of molecules in it.
Now they dissociate.
That's what the aq means.
Those are neutral.
Here, it's a solid, but
you can understand this
from looking at it
and thinking about it.
Look at the way those water
molecules are oriented.
They're pointing to the
cl with their positivity,
with positive charge.
And they're pointing to the
sodium with the negative,
and that's how they find
happiness in water--
because they're ions, and
water can be either way.
It can point its
dipole in either--
and so it can actually bond.
Remember, the hydrogen has
got a little positive charge
because the oxygen took it.
And so that's what
the-- it has a dipole,
and that's able to
turn around and bond
and be happy with
each of these ions.
That's why salt dissolves--
because it can
find a happy place.
Other reasons exist
outside of this class,
like entropy, thermodynamics.
But this is how we're going
to picture it as energetically
happy.
It can become happy.
So we've dissolved some things.
We've got to start
thinking about the thing
that I mentioned before, which
is how much can I dissolve?
How much can I dissolve?
And in that, it gets
into this table here.
There it is.
So that's how much.
And you see it's listed
there as moles per 100 grams.
And so that's one
way to write it.
You could write it as--
it's often the max solubility is
often what we're interested in.
And you could write it
in moles per 100 grams.
You could write it
in moles per liter.
Well that's something that
we've already learned.
That's m form last
Friday, the molarity.
Or it could be in grams.
Sometimes you'll see
it in grams per liter.
So don't get bogged
down by the units.
It's just how much of this
stuff were you able to dissolve?
If we look at sugar--
here's sugar, here's salt--
how much sugar can dissolve?
I'm not going to cram it in.
So for sugar, the
max is 1,800, so I'm
going to do both those units--
1,800 grams per liter.
And if you convert that,
it's 5.26 moles per liter.
That's how much sugar you
can dissolve in water.
By the way, I did a
quick calculation,
and that's 429 teaspoons.
That's 429 teaspoons.
I don't know what
everybody is saying--
Coke has so much sugar.
Coke's got only 26
teaspoons per liter.
You could put a lot
more in, if they wanted.
I'll go the other way.
I challenge them to go
near the solubility limit.
They're not even close.
Too much sugar.
So salt-- you can also look
at salt. For salt, what is it?
Salt is 359 grams per
liter, and then that's it.
That's 6.14.
This is nacl.
It's interesting-- if you
compare sodium chloride with
sodium bromide--
so if you look at sodium
bromide, it's going to be 8.9.
And sodium fluoride
there's only going to be 1.
Why?
Because it comes right
down to the picture.
I've got to make these happier.
I've got to make them happier.
If you've got the ions there,
and the water likes it,
but what if they really didn't
have a strong ionic bond
to start with?
You can imagine you might
be able to get to a higher
amount of dissociation.
Or what if they had a
very strong ionic bond?
You might imagine
that less of it--
you've got a lower
maximum solubility.
So it all kind of goes
together with the things
that we've learned.
But what we're
really talking about
is what I need to
tell you about next.
And that is this idea that we've
reached a dynamic equilibrium.
We've reached a
dynamic equilibrium.
So what does that mean?
Well, if it's unsaturated--
so if it's unsaturated,
I'm way before this limit.
This is salt. That's
the limit max.
Max.
What does it mean?
What does it mean
to be below it?
Well, what does it mean to
even have reached the maximum
itself?
What it means is not that
things aren't dissolving.
What it means is that things
are reforming, recrystallizing
at the same rate that
they're dissolving.
That's what the maximum means,
and that's an equilibrium.
And that's why we're
going to talk about next.
So if it's unsaturated,
there's a nice little molecular
picture.
There's the thing you're
dissolving, and look at them.
They're going away
into solution.
Maybe it's salt
breaking up into ions.
Maybe it's sugar.
They're going into solution
and finding a happy place
around the water.
But once in a while,
one of them comes back.
You see that little
particle there coming back.
That happens.
But much more,
they're dissolving.
Then, you reach this point of
saturation where it cannot--
where it's going
to recrystallize,
reform the solid at the
same rate that you dissolve.
And that's the place where
you can't dissolve anymore.
So what's really
happening is that you
have a solute plus a solvent,
and it's not going one way
as we've been writing it down.
It's going both ways.
So it's actually the solute
plus the solvent goes like this.
That is what we've
been talking about.
That's dissolution, and that's
the predominant mechanism
on the left before
you've saturated.
But see, and that
goes to some solution.
But see, you can
also precipitate.
Precipitation.
And so at the saturated
solution, you have--
if it's saturated, then that's
another way of saying we've
reached the max possible
concentration of the solute.
Remember, the little brackets
means concentration, molarity.
It means that these rates--
thinking back to Friday--
are the same.
It means these
rates are the same.
This is a dynamic equilibrium.
And so that's what we need
now the tools to talk about.
And so we're going to
talk about three things--
the reaction quotient, the
equilibrium constant k,
chemical equilibrium, and
then the solubility product.
Now if you think about--
I just said this is like
the forward reaction is
going in the same--
it's happening in the
same rate as the reverse.
And so if you think about
this as like a graph
of concentrations--
so I'll just put here
concentrations and time--
then maybe I have started--
I've put my salt. I pour a
teaspoon of salt in water,
and the salt is dissolving.
So it's going into the products.
It starts out at
zero in solution,
and then it becomes products.
At the same time, maybe
I've started it up here,
and these are the reactants--
Gesundheit-- that
look like this--
Gesundheit-- and those
would be the reactants.
So the concentrations
of these things--
at a certain point,
they're changing.
And then, at a certain
point, they're not changing.
But they're still reactions
happening back and forth
like I just showed you.
It's a dynamic equilibrium.
Now what we do is we write down
for some arbitrary reaction--
aa plus, so let's
go back to this one.
But now, we're going to
write it going both ways--
cc plus dd.
You can define the
reaction quotient q--
that's the first thing--
as the concentrations
c of the products--
c to the c, d to the d,
over a to the a, b to the b.
Please do not confuse
this with the rates.
Yeah.
I've been talking about
the rates being equal.
That's not from the rates.
Remember, the exponents
of the rate law
come from experimental
measurements.
The reaction quotient comes
from the stoichiometric
coefficients.
Why?
These exponents here have to
do literally with probabilities
of reaction, of reacting.
It has to do with the fact
that if I've got two of c,
then you multiply the amount
of c times another amount of c
in the same volume.
It has to do with
probabilities of reacting.
That's where you
get those exponents,
and they're directly from the
stoichiometric coefficients.
They do not need to be
experimentally measured.
Once you have this, you
have the reaction quotient.
Now, why is this useful,
this reaction quotient?
Well, it's useful because there
is a very special place where
now it doesn't change anymore.
These concentrations
aren't changing.
Reactions are still happening,
but the concentrations
aren't changing-- no change.
If there is no change, then--
Gesundheit-- then q isn't
changing because it's just
a ratio of concentrations.
It's a ratio of concentrations
equal to this whole thing, not
just the top line.
The reaction quotient is
related to the concentrations.
So if the concentration
zone changes
even if reactions are happening
still, it's a constant.
So at this point, q
equals a constant,
and that is an
equilibrium constant.
So we'll call it keq.
It's a dynamic equilibrium.
k represents a
dynamic equilibrium.
And what's really useful about
k is that for a given reaction,
k is a constant.
I just said it.
But it doesn't
matter-- if we're--
it depends on temperature.
But if I keep the temperature
fixed, k won't change.
It's a constant.
It's the constant that tells
me where equilibrium is.
Now there's one more thing
that we've got to write down--
that third one there.
I'm going to put it on here.
So k is an equilibrium constant.
That's a general constant.
But now, I'm going
to turn my attention
from any old reaction--
my k is actually very general
concept for equilibrium.
We are in this class going
to use it for solubility.
That's how we are using
the equilibrium constant.
And so the ksp is the
solubility product,
and it's an
equilibrium constant.
Equilibrium constant that
is related to solubility.
It is literally the product of
solubilities in equilibrium.
That is literally what it means.
So we're going to do some
examples to see that.
It's an equilibrium-- so it's
a constant of equilibrium.
And it's called--
Gesundheit-- it's
called the solubility
product, because it's
related to the equilibrium
of dissolving something,
dissolving some
solute in a solvent.
Now we're going to do
examples with salts.
So we're going to be
dissolving salts and talking
about equilibrium constants
in that dissolution,
otherwise known as the
solubility product.
It's just an
equilibrium constant.
There are many.
This is the one we're
going to care about,
and we're going to
do it for salts.
And so one of the
things you've got to--
so nacl-- that was kind of easy.
That became a cation and
an anion in solution.
But salts can be made of
many, many different types
of cations, and there's lists
that go on and on and on.
Here are some, and
they get named.
So here's some of the anions.
Oh, chlorine-- we
just did that one.
Bromine-- you can
also have a carbonate.
You could have chromates,
hydroxides, oxalates,
sulfates, sulfides, and the
list goes on and on and on.
There are many, many of these.
They don't have to
be a single atom.
It can be a part of a salt
that breaks off and has
a negative charge.
That's an anion, and here
are some of the cations--
sodium, potassium, calcium.
And you know about these things.
We've been talking
about these things.
And you know if it's sodium,
then you know it's only going
to lose-- it's only
going to be na+.
It doesn't have a second
weakly-bonded electron to lose.
So it's really only
going to be na+.
But then you get--
and calcium is going
to be calcium 2+.
It's got two, magnesium two.
And then transition metals
are a little more complicated.
They can be a little
more complicated.
Iron can be 2+ or 3+.
It depends, and on and
on and on for those.
And so we'll do a few examples.
We'll do a few examples.
We'll get into the mood.
And I want to do it-- first, I'm
going to do an example that's
actually a classic
example, because it
doesn't dissolve very well,
but it's silver chloride.
Now sodium chloride is--
sodium chloride goes all the way
to the point where it basically
dissolves so well.
So you can imagine
the equilibrium
for sodium chloride
goes way to the right.
But for silver chloride,
it's different.
For silver chloride,
So we're going to
look at this curve.
And I'll talk about this curve.
Don't worry.
We're coming to it.
We are coming to it.
Let me start in
the middle again.
Because what the
equilibrium constant
does, given the definition
that I have just hidden,
unfortunately, is it allows
us to go back and forth.
If I know the
equilibrium constant,
then I can get how much one
of these ions is soluble.
I can get the maximum
solubility of it.
So let's take an example.
So here's a question.
How much agcl dissolves
in 1 liter of water?
That's such a good question.
I don't know.
But I do know that
the solubility product
that this equilibrium
constant for sodium chloride
is 1.7 times 10
to the minus 10th.
Now if I write down the
dissolution reaction,
sodium chloride solid
is going to go to--
sorry, sodium silver--
silver plus in solution.
So we put the aqueous plus
chlorine minus in solution.
And it is going to
go back and forth.
And so the ksp for this
is going to equal--
I'm going to go with the
equation that I wrote down--
the concentration of silver to
the 1 times the concentration
of chlorine minus--
these are ions--
divided by the concentration
of silver chloride solid.
Now we get to another thing.
Remember, I got rid of water,
because water is everywhere.
It's the solvent.
So you don't need to put it into
these equilibrium calculations.
Well, it's the same
thing with the solid.
So if I think about
this a little bit,
this equilibrium is
between dissolved.
It's between the ions
that are dissolving.
But there from this
reaction, from the way
it's written there, I've got a
solid form of silver chloride.
So this is not-- so this is the
concentration of solid silver
chloride in the solid.
This is just a constant.
That's not going to change.
Common misunderstanding.
It doesn't change.
So we get rid of it, because it
gets folded into the constant.
That's always the same.
The concentration of
this is always the same.
And so we get rid of it.
So now we have the ksp is
equal to, in this case,
ag+ times cl-.
Talk about solubility product.
Solubilities concentrate.
The solubility is--
when I add this in,
it reaches some
equilibrium where they're
dissolving and reforming.
I wanted to know at what point
that is, what concentrations
is that going to be.
This is them.
So solubility
product-- right there.
I used the definition
of equilibrium constant.
And now I can use this reaction.
I can use this reaction because
the stoichiometric coefficients
tell me--
they tell me both what
the exponents there are--
1-- but they also tell me
the relative molar amounts
of these things.
It's the same.
So if x equals the
concentration of silver plus,
then it must also equal the
concentration of cl minus.
If you just let x equal
the concentration,
that comes from the reaction.
1 in front of silver,
1 in front of chlorine.
And so that means now
that you can solve it
because x squared is equal to
1.7 times 10 to the minus 10th,
and x equals 1.3 times
10 to the minus fifth, m,
and that equals
these concentrations.
That equals the
concentration of silver plus.
So that is how much,
in equilibrium-- this
is an equilibrium
constant-- that
is how much you will get of
these ions dissolved in water.
Now there is a nice way to
set this up that is often
taught in high school.
I like it.
I think it's a good
way to keep track.
And so if you were
wanting to keep track,
and you like tables, there's
something called the ICE table.
And in this case, it's a little
bit boring, but as you'll see,
it can actually wind
up being pretty useful,
especially when we
add other ions, which
are going to do soon.
So ICE is initial
change equilibrium.
Initial change equilibrium.
It's just a way of keeping
track of what I just did,
because I started with
some amount of solid,
and I had zero.
I put it into water.
I had zero, but then I added
1.3 times 10 to the minus fifth,
and I added 1.3 times
10 to the minus fifth.
And so my equilibrium is a
little less, a little less
solid.
And over here, it's
just these numbers.
That was indeed boring,
but have no fear.
It becomes helpful.
It becomes helpful because
what we're going to do next--
not right now--
but on Wednesday,
what we're going to do
is we're going to mess
with this equilibrium.
Oh, equilibrium, I'm
going to throw you off.
And equilibrium is
saying, no you're
not, because I'm equilibrium,
and I will always be found.
And that's called Le Chatelier's
Principle, and what that does
is it allows us
to really go back,
and we get to actually add a
bunch of chlorine ions to this,
and we're going to see what
happens to this balance.
It will find equilibrium.
And we have the tools now
to know how to find it.
That's that green curve there.
This is what we're
going to work with.
There's the concentration
of chlorine.
There's a concentration
of silver in ions.
You see the dissolved chlorine
on the x-axis, dissolved silver
on the y-axis.
And look at that.
I've got that point
b there that is
where these things
have found equilibrium
when it's not messed with.
Now the thing is, if you
were a reaction happening,
and you hadn't gotten
to equilibrium yet--
so I hadn't added
much silver chloride--
if that was the case, then
you might be at point d.
Notice that the reaction
quotient, q, is less
than the equilibrium constant.
q is less.
That means it's
going to be driven
to dissolve more than
it precipitates until it
gets to point B on this curve.
You could also be way, way out
with a much higher q point, e,
and you know it has
to find equilibrium.
It's going to find
equilibrium, which
is what we just calculated.
Those are the concentrations
of equilibrium.
It has to get back to point
B. It's going to do it
by precipitating out solid.
It's gone too far.
But you can see that
equilibrium can also be had
and will be had.
It shall be had.
Because k never changes if
you fix the temperature.
k is the same.
So I can mess with
this in other ways.
I can go and add a
whole bunch of chlorine,
and it will come back down
onto that green curve.
It will come back down
onto that green curve,
which is the curve
that guarantees
k is the same constant.
That's what that green curve is.
And there's one last point
I'm going to make today,
and that is units.
Units of k depend--
it was like the rate law.
It depends on the reaction.
Look, a concentration
is a concentration.
That was deep.
Units are capital
M moles per liter.
But that means that k--
k is two of those
multiplied together.
So in this case, k has
units of m squared.
It must, or it wouldn't work.
k can have units of m cubed.
We will pick up
here on Wednesday,
and we'll cover more
of this, more examples
before we move on
to acids and bases.